[music]
Iago now in another
corner now
I throw
ro
now he went along the
line now
[music]
let's change it he just threw it in another
corner at a different
angle now let's change it
again and he threw the same thing again
Ade
naha and he moves as if along the whole
triangle
[music]
Well well constantly this scheme as if to keep
in his brain in order to move the
triangle the fourth
option
[music]
he imagines as if all the time the lines
triangle all the time
triangle
triangular
round and
square this
principle
I do it
like this the point of the triangle is
there And everything is as if right there where he
showed
the forging on the
street